RYAN MATSUMOTO: Today, we're
talking about careers, MLOps,
data transfer, and communities.
I'm Ryan, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
The cloud computing
industry is booming,
and experts are in high demand.
To help meet this demand
and democratize opportunity,
Google Cloud is introducing
its first virtual certification
journey learning program for
underrepresented communities
across the United States,
Cloud Career Jump Start.
The program is free
of charge and includes
technical and professional
skill development and resources
to provide readiness
for certification
via the Google Cloud
Associate Cloud Engineer exam.
Check out the blog for
eligibility and details.
We recently published
our MLOps framework
to help organizations
come up to speed faster
in this important domain.
And to help ML practitioners
translate the framework
into actionable steps,
we released a blog post
that highlights some of
the factors that influence
where to begin, based
on our experience
in working with customers.
Overseeing a Cloud
migration is a tough job,
but moving your actual data
there doesn't have to be.
With the availability of our
latest transfer appliance
for the US, EU, and
Singapore regions,
we're providing a simple,
secure, cost-effective,
and offline way to
transfer petabytes of data
from data centers and field
locations into Google Cloud.
Check out the blog for use
cases and more information.
Helping developers
be their best is
core to Google Cloud's mission.
So, we're excited to
announce investment
in two new communities--
the Google Cloud community
and a partnership with
collectives on Stack Overflow.
Both communities will serve
to enhance creativity, foster
greater collaboration,
and contribute
to the overall success of
our developer community
and our valued customer base.
They'll also provide a globally
connected source of information
for faster answers and
recognition of contributions.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.